daniel l'atild alberta chirurgien orl et
président du syndicat maire monsieur
l'attila d'albertas bienvenue sur arte
france merci d'être en direct alors vous
savez avait saisi le conseil d'état avec
votre collectif vous demander plusieurs
choses dont de recevoir davantage de
masques pourquoi parce que je leur tour
que j'ai de mes confrères tous mes
confrères médecin généraliste et médecin
traitant et et c'est le manque de match
cruelle pour affronter le lait cette
épidémie et on sait que comme on n'en
voit pas un pompier retraité et est
arrêté en ce sens zoé ben on n'envoie
pas un médecin sans masques ffp2 qui le
protège complètement de ce risque
épidémique et encore de façon partielle
mais le sait le sait aujourd'hui la
recommandation de toutes les sociétés
scientifiques alors des masques ffp2
pour le personnel soignant mais vous
demandez également des masques
chirurgicaux pour tous les français
c'est l'expérience l'expérience des pays
qui ont lutté contre ce phénomène
c'est les pays asiatiques et c'est les
pays qui ont systématiquement des
masques
il ya une politique il faut changer de
paradigme aujourd'hui en france il ya
une politique de protection de la
population avec des masques protection
du personnel médical avec des masques
ffp2 dépistage systématique dans les
zones où c'est encore possible parce que
des zones comme le grand test c'est plus
du tout possible en étant une médecine
de guerre et médecine de catastrophe
on est on est plus dans une belle-fille
de dépistage alors que dans des zones
comme la la région sud de la france on
n'est pas encore dans une catastrophe
donc il faut dépister maintenant
dépister pour retrouver les ports les
porteurs et les isoler de façon plus
efficace et éventuellement administré ce
traitement qui permet un portage de
virémie beaucoup moins importants que
l'évolution de naturel de ce portage
c'est l'individu immunologiquement
compétents alors nous parler de
dépistage massif ans avait été
d'ailleurs préconisée par l'om est ce la
france ne l'a pas fait pourquoi parce
qu'elle manque de moyens matériels pour
procéder justement au dépistage massif
de la population
c'est ce qu'on nous dit c'est ce qu'on
nous dit effectivement que il ya un
angle de mais aujourd'hui par exemple
dans la région paca dans la région du
sud de la france
vous avez là beaucoup de laboratoires
privés qui se sont mis à dépister de
façon et ils sont prêts ils se mettent
près au service de la population pour
dépister largement tous les gens qu'il
le souhaite
je crois qu'il faut organiser ce
dépistage pas faire un grand n'importe
quoi continue et le confinement en
organisant un dépistage qui doit être
fait par des professionnels parce que la
technique de prise de prélèvement est
très particulière et donc peut pas être
c'est pas une technique qui peut être
fait par le patient lui-même
je pense que c'est une technique de ce
fait par un professionnel qui doit être
de bien au courant de l'anatomie des
fosses nasales pour faire un vrai
brossage des fosses nasales pour avoir
un prélèvement qui soit analysable et
qu'ils puissent être exploitées alors il
ya un traitement expérimental on le sait
associant la chloroquine avec un autre
antibiotiques pour l'instant il n'est
pas administré systématiquement vous
vous demandez qu'il ne soit pourquoi
parce que c'est le seul traitement qui a
montré une efficacité sur le portage et
le diminution de la virémie aujourd'hui
on n'est pas dans les vies dance baise
médecine
on est dans la médecine 2 2
intuition et cette étude même si elle
est courte et même si elle n'est pas
effectivement qu'elle ne suit pas les
evidence based medecine mais il faut la
mettre en application dans cet état de
crise que l'on subit donc ça veut dire
quoi que l'état en fonds est en train de
répond probablement la crise passée de
masques pas de dépistage massif pas
d'utilisation de chloroquine est un
français est en train de se tromper
selon vous aujourd'hui l'état français
sur ce et conseillé par aig des comités
scientifiques qui lui disent parce que
ce n'est pas à l'état français qui
décident puisqu'il est essentielle
foncièrement que des scientifiques
derrière qui les aide mais je crois que
il ya eu un défaut de prise de
conscience de la gravité de cette temps
d'amy est donc aujourd'hui par ce
recours au conseil d'état
c'est pour ces poupaud à titre à titre
citoyen pour protéger la population les
soignants avec les masques pour essayer
de généraliser ces tests de dépistage
dans la mesure où c'est possible et
mettre en place ce traitement médical
qu'il rompt le c diminuent le portage
mère-fille aujourd'hui aux hospitaliers
alors qu on demande qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient mis en vente libre comme c'était
le cas depuis 40 ans puisque certains
médicaments qui est très ancien merci à
daniel l'atild alberta d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin aurait les que vous faites
partie du collectif le sma merkel à qui
a saisi le conseil d'état merci d'avoir
et en direct